SPEAKER 1: We've talked a bit
about how Kubeflow can help
and seen one way to set it up.
There's a lot you can
do once it's set up.
So let's break down some of
the components of Kubeflow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today we'll go through
and give an overview
of some of the biggest
components of Kubeflow.
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link
below to read more
about the components
of Kubeflow.
As you've heard us say
before, machine learning
can be complicated.
There's lots of different
pieces involved,
like handling and validating
your data, training your model,
evaluating it, and
eventually serving it.
Since Kubeflow handles multiple
parts of the ML experience,
it's made to be
flexible and composable.
You can use the
pieces you want to
and swap out for the
other parts as needed.
Let's take a quick look at
some of the most commonly used
components available to you.
We'll do more deep
dives in future videos.
First and foremost,
there's the user interface.
You can think of this
as your dashboard
to manage your ML projects.
You can launch other components,
get useful information
about your cluster, and find
quick links to documentation.
If you're working
with multiple teams,
you may want to set up
namespaces for each team
to work in.
Users who have access
to multiple namespaces
can choose which one they're
working on at the top.
There's a lot more behind
the interface, though.
Kubeflow also comes with an
integrated Jupyter notebook
environment.
Notebooks are useful
for doing quick tests,
developing models, and
writing application code.
It's not uncommon for ML
engineers and data scientists
to run their notebooks
locally and get constrained
by resources, like
trying to train
a large model on your laptop.
Kubeflow also supports
multi-user support
through namespaces,
so it's easier
to collaborate
and manage access.
Having notebooks in
your cluster makes
it easy to run jobs
where resources
can be dynamically scaled.
We'll talk more about
notebooks in the next video.
Another important
component is Katib,
which can be used for automated
hyperparameter tuning.
Hyperparameter tuning
plays a major part
in developing good
models, and manually
searching a hyperparameter
space can take a lot of effort.
Katib helps you optimize
your hyperparameter values
around a metric you've
chosen, such as the accuracy
of the model.
It's a helpful way
to find and visualize
the optimum
configuration to prepare
your model for production.
Next up, Kubeflow Pipelines
is a powerful platform
to help you build
end-to-end ML workflows.
Pipelines lets you
build a set of steps
to handle everything
from collecting data
to serving your model.
It's based on
containers, so each step
is portable and scalable.
You can run your same Pipelines
code across environments
and share it with others.
And since each step
is independent,
you can reuse Pipelines
steps for different pipelines
and experiments.
Chances are you're
probably going
to want to train your model.
Kubeflow supports several
ML frameworks for training,
such as TensorFlow and PyTorch.
Kubeflow defines custom
Kubernetes resources
for distributed
training jobs, so you
can create a config
file that specifies
the details you want
to use for training
and let it handle the rest.
You have the
flexibility to choose
the tools you want to
use, or you're already
using, to train and
retrain your model.
We'll walk through some
training in future videos.
Of course, your models
may not be too useful
unless you can actually
make predictions with them.
Kubeflow can serve your models
with multiple frameworks
like TF Serving,
KFServing, and Seldon Core.
You could even plug in your
own serving system if needed,
but KFServing can help abstract
most common ML frameworks.
It's built on Knative,
a framework for running
serverless apps on Kubernetes.
That way, you can serve
your model and access
all the resources you need
without having to handle
the complexities directly.
This is just a brief overview
of the major components
in Kubeflow.
There's lots of examples you
can try out for yourself.
But we'll also go
deeper and talk more
about each of these
in upcoming videos.
Check out the link below
to try it out for yourself,
and stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]